the Oasis it's a place with the limits
of reality are your own imagination IMAX
brings volume it changes the scale of
the viewing experience the IMAX
iteration ready player one is
spectacular because it was conceived for
that format ready player one is kind of
a dream project there was so much
potential for creating something really
unique and interesting and IMAX it's an
amazing thing to see the Oasis well is
absolutely incredible
and this was really a great opportunity
to sort of exploit some of that
technology when you're dealing with huge
battle scenes and the number of
individual characters and the complexity
of the scenes it is absolutely crazy
I only use technology to tell a better
story and IMAX puts you closer to the
experience of being inside the movie
seeing it in IMAX makes the Oasis seem
beautiful and really elegant and more
like what I imagined the Oasis could be
cozy ready player one is gonna be the
movie people are gonna look at for years
and years when people see this movie
they're gonna know that they're seeing
something different something new and
something unique players are you ready
[Music]